we are here with the owner of the lost
kitchen erin french
and
i mean your show on discovery plus is my
favorite it's fantastic you guys have to
watch it and we are going to celebrate
cookies because that's what we're doing
all week long and erin is going to show
us her favorite recipe right now you're
in the driver's seat i'm your passenger
okay this is one of my favorite recipes
ever this is something we used to have
at the holidays all the time when i was
a little girl growing up and we would
only have them on thanksgiving and
christmas my grandmother would make
these and i would make sure that i was
wearing a christmas dress or you know a
holiday dress that i could have pockets
so i could go sneak in and i could stuff
them in because i was just very addicted
to these cookies and you'll find out why
but she would never give me this recipe
ever never gave it to me even when i
started to really get into cooking nope
not giving it to me
and she passed away
and then years later my aunt found this
collection of all these recipes from
casseroles and you know very
old-fashioned like 1960s and 70s food
and i looked and it was like i think
this might be the recipe and i made the
cookies and i tasted my grandmother
after she was very much gone so this is
a special recipe and maybe she's mad at
me because i'm sharing it now because
she'd never share it with me and now i'm
just giving it to everyone but
i'm sharing it with the world now but i
did add my own secret ingredient so then
i can make it mine but that's what you
do with recipes you you pass it down so
okay so we're starting it's with um we
started this with some uh shortening and
sugar and you cream it all nice and
creamy with shortening and sugar until
it gets nice and fluffy
so
once nice and fluffy that's just going
straight to my i thought it's going to
be great
this is why you only make this twice a
year yeah literally i'm like okay so
that's going to end up there and there
perfect
and then um the next thing we'll do is
we'll just add in the eggs and you just
add them one at a time because eggs like
to be incorporated gently and also make
sure they're room temperature eggs
because
that's just going to be very helpful
with your dough so things don't really
just get bound up all right we've got to
the eggs in there we're going to add in
the molasses
so that'll make it nice and rich
and then
we can just turn this down i like to
turn it off and give a little whisk
so over here we've got the flour and
then you've got all those spices that
taste like the holidays so you know
you've got your ginger and cinnamon and
cloves and that just gets a little bit
of a whisk in here
and then you're going to gently add it
in and then that'll make our batter so
when you're mixing in flour you don't
want to mix it very on high the gluten
will start to form and then you'll have
tough cookies so you just want to do a
little bit at a time and we love a tough
cookie but not now not this kind
got it exactly
so it's so easy it just goes right in
and then
twist that in the dough starts to come
together really simply and as it's
coming together there's all this candy
ginger and this is my added touch to my
nanny's recipe because i just thought it
was a little adult and grown up to add
in candied ginger you keep getting those
little ginger bites and
it's just
it's delicious and the great thing about
this cookie is that it's it's soft on
the inside and then it's a little chewy
on the outside
so the next thing we do is we're just
going to take the dough
and
scoop it out with our little
portioners here perfect so just make
your nice little balls of cookie here
and then roll them in the sugar because
you know why not
sometimes i give them a little pressed
down so they bake
just just so
and then
we'll pop them in the oven
and when they come out you'll see
you've got like the most perfect ginger
cookies of your childhood dreams how
long in the oven time and temp you know
usually for baking i'm in like the 350
375 range um and then
they bake for about eight to ten minutes
and you just wanna pull them out just as
they're starting to crack because
they're almost kind of nice when they're
just a little bit under done on the
inside so they have that cookie
gooeyness it's true i don't like a dried
out cookie so um yeah so we pop these in
the oven
350
8 minutes maybe check keep checking
cracking
cooking is like sailing and you have to
constantly watch your environment and
move around but yeah so they come out
and look
they're soft they're soft cheers
[Music]
so good
oh my god it's my grandmother
i love it
thank you for bringing us
into the moment by the way you are such
a good storyteller the apron with the
pocket and the stealing and then asking
your grandmother and then finding her
resume i
i will always remember i have pockets
feel free load up
listen i'm probably that weird old lady
i will be that woman with like a
baguette under her arm and some cookies
yeah in my pocket
i'll be there with you i'm fine
i'm honored to meet you
i'm in awe of what you've built for
yourself
i appreciate you sharing your story with
people so that
those of us when we go through things
can be encouraged to believe we can find
and do extraordinary things
i really really admire you and i was so
excited to meet you today
chefs are my marvel universe you're like
meeting thor
so
thank you
thank you so much thank you
go to our website for the full recipe
and be sure to check out aaron's show
the lost kitchen available now on
discovery plus and the magnolia app
[Music]